[音楽]
していた
me
[音楽]
いらっしゃいませんスターバック生ようこそ
弾み成長です皆さんスターバックスいかがですかまずここまで運んできたことを褒めて
ほしい
ここにありますのはあのメニュー表の左下の方のお茶的なやつを取り除いてつ全部買っ
てきましたすごい大英断だぼクリームは溶けしもうなんか大変なことになってるんです
けどさすがスターバックス行ってきもーれずに運び出すことができました
それ以降回だ
4しようかと言いますとあのボクスターまあそんなに行かないんですよたまに
アーマーにの部位なんですよバニラクリームフラペチーノ
もうなんか好きなものが決まればそれしか飲まないんで俺これ以外多分俺の休暇助けば
どんなことないんですよねもう今回は二間に言ってるこの飲み物をお茶とか混ぜると
もちろん変になりそうなんであのちゃんと美味しいのを作りたいんですよ今回スタバに
行っている
野間も全部買ったんでこれは全部混ぜたらもうもう2て全部美味しい理由でしょう全部
飲んだことないけど全部美味しいわけなんだか混ぜたらも至極の史上最強4カラーの
ようなできると思ったんで今回ソロやっていこうと思います
て理由て付けなことこれで俺は全種類端にすることができる
これを機にば逆に向けられているので美味しいやつ見つけちゃおうかいなっ
羽でさっそく全種類のあっ混ぜていこうと思います別ら go to heaven
in the world champion
来月28歳です
節水で早速祭良い子と思いますまずはもう俺はこれしかの番ぐらいバニラクリーム
フラペチーノ
うわぁいただきます
これすごいたってにこのまま飲みたいは落ち等お茶
バーリーが家ダーク m チップへ絶対違うけどそう書いてあんだよなダークモカ
チップフラペチーノかな
ああおいしいけどやっぱりやっぱんじゃなかな
satc エロさといっしょ
ブーバーにょか今度からこれでしょ
夏厨がもう宇宙夏帆
今の所失敗です色だけ見ると今の顔失敗です
sc ついまあ誰かで働いてる人のわかるなもの scs 中まいります
あー止めても甘えの飲みすぎて足がバカな海
マンゴーパッション降ってついのをいただきますうんまぁスタバというか仲間って言っ
てそうなんですね
これ
まずないほうが良かったこれお値段で見たかったんですよねメルティーナ松尾れた
フラペチーノパターンのが乗ってますねこれ今季節限定らしいですぞ
いただきます
[音楽]
ハーイん
いや忘れちゃったナンバーは安全性の見なかったさあチョコ温度たフラペチーノ
これまたも事実をいただきますねえっじゃあ中にもチョコがいる
うーん甘党どれからするとと学んだこれ療法
次から頼みますアーマーい競馬終わりました
正直ここまででいいまであるこの姫飲めないですよ僕なんで多分絶対フラペチーノを
頼む民営なんてちょっとここから先の表の存知は
ブーブーいしいっ
なって頑張っ
コーヒーフラペチーノこれなんでこんなんでこの甘いと2階の下がるだろう
ここはまあ
アイスカフェモカ窪田わかんないけどアバ竜真今日は急に頭打つするだけ心臓バクバク
すぎました
またスコッチだって今なおに聞いたことがないんですけど
[音楽]
んまぬ愛 scm なねこれなんか10度名前なにこういう購読だっ
能力予防たぶんこの動画は3回と音のリアクションが良い奴は本当に甘いやつです
アホアホガード s ペーターもガーのプラグチップばあちゃんバッケス
やや苦し甘さが足りなムースフォームじゃべるまきあーとかな
ビッアメリカーノポップアイスコーヒー
うんアーモンドミルクだってうーんなんとでスムース坊村ってやります
[音楽]
はいばいうわけで前場添えましていた
いやぁなかなかですねやっぱり色んな色で奴があるから混ぜるとどうしてもこんな感じ
になっちゃうんですね温め色を均等に主義はまたいろいろ変わりいたします混ぜていき
ます
prepare to do
よしよし願いいろいろ浮遊物がありますがおおよそこんなもんでしょ
はい
大
できました
こちら88アイスコーヒーコールドプレイコーヒーアイススターバックス大豆たん白
船出と匂いするブースフォーム長いさあ求めるからダイス金も帰って微笑んでもアイス
キャラメルマキアートティームフォームもキャラメル理由は大豆バタースコッチら台
スマホダービーの
作り村口之町108に雑魚がチップクリーム愛する頭からハルちゃんちいコンピュータ
で売られちゃうっていうかそれをやる講義がんじゃなければそれだな街ぶらちんだ
まだバージョン手ぶらでの初めから飛行機やベルじゃない方やチョコレートです1番線
常勝にゃ見た感じは普通になうっていうと桜
ではない匂いでぜひ
駄菓子屋さんでお願いしますいただきます
[音楽]
たっ日はん
奪えなんだうまいぞ牛乳にコーンフレークを入れてコーンフレークだけ食った味の染み
た残りの牛乳同じがします
いや美味しいですねやっぱり甘いの見方のほうが多いんですね
だから多分結局全体通っとほどよい苦味も保ちつついろんな味がか頑張って
2 new mice はまっつも効きすぎてないんだかオレンジ
のマンゴーと見たけどそれもなんかあんまり感じませんめっすごい c ここはって
感じるん
[音楽]
ごちそうさまでしたーー
いやすいませんもちろん一人では全部飲めませんあのちょっとあの想定外にたくさん
できてしまったんでみんなにも飲んでもらおうと思います
[音楽]
第あるぞ
新作一斗
[音楽]
ていました
あああああ
よろしくお願います jan
あっはーるへ行っは